the blues was born right here in the
mississippi delta
john lee hooker muddy waters jimmy king
jessie mayhem pill
i can't see him anymore
but that spirit lives on
right here
[Music]
i can lose myself in music hear it
i feel it
and it transports me to another time and
place
some would call it a religious
experience
i can't say that i disagree
[Music]
it makes me think of all the ways people
around the world connect to god
moses saw god in a bush
buddha
found enlightenment under a tree
muhammad experienced allah on a mountain
is there some universal concept of god
that all religions share
or
is god fundamentally different to people
of different faiths
i'm setting out to discover
who god is
god wants to be your best friend
to find out how believers around the
world see the divine the holy people are
around us right now
i'll explore how the identity of god
has changed over the millennia
he thought that there were too many gods
and not enough focus was on him
i'll learn how many gods merged into one
it's a single force that gives the order
to our whole world
and our search for the presence of god
so you're looking for physical
manifestations of god yes inside my
brain
[Music]
i grew up with the christian concept of
god
a single divine being who created and
governs the universe
of jesus as god's earthly incarnation
i know that's not the way everyone sees
the divine
i want to know how other religions see
god
so
i'm going to india
to hindus
there's not one god
there are millions
busy little fur affair
in the holy city of varanasi i'm meeting
historian bender barangipe
to find out how hindus see their guards
at every corner of the lane
and just to see anywhere and you see a
shrine and no corner they can leave
without having a guard there so like we
have got this small little shrine here
and it has got that elephant-headed god
ganesha
yeah so god removes the obstacles
removes obstacles
[Music]
hindu deities come in many forms
some are male
some female
some are part human part animal
each one has its specific powers
so she's the goddess of disease
disease yeah so when you're deceased
your body gets inflamed then you invoke
her and she sends the cool breeze right
and the body gets cold all right
here's a question for you you've got a
choice of america millions and millions
of guards
how do you choose usually it's the
family
the family each family has but one
family deity
and that is passed on to the next
generation or sometimes in the times of
distress
one goes to a god and say or goddess
that please
take me out of this difficult times and
forever i'll worship you as my personal
god or goddess
i'm interested in finding out how these
statues become vessels for divine beings
how hindus connect to their gods
so
bender is taking me to an intimate
prayer ritual
yeah
can you hear these chants which are
going on
they're chanting the chants for invoking
the goddess
so now we are going to be blessed
[Music]
[Music]
this prayer ceremony is dedicated to the
goddess
this is lolita here
this is her
physical representation
[Music]
so all the potential is still in her
so she has got the highest form of
energy in her
and she
gives that power
to others to fight against
[Music]
[Music]
and with every name they will offer
[Music]
so anything in this level that we have
pronounced
goes to the goddess so by saying these
thousand words you have almost covered
all the possible syllables that you
could averted so you can work over just
a banana syllable the goddess is in the
form of speech the human sound
and the world is supposed to have been
created out of these rhythms
for her devotees
exists in the rhythmic energy of their
chanting
a divine energy that powers their lives
anyway the goddess has blessed you
that she has invited you here
[Music]
seeing this ceremony really helps me
understand what god means to hindus
behind all the gods ender tells me there
is a single divine energy that believers
seek to tap into they say that it's just
a principle it's like pure energy form
which is neither a male or a female or
having any name
so they have just given one name brahman
so in the western church in christianity
judaism even islam
there is one god it's just it's pure
energies there's no name you can put to
him there's no face you can put to them
there's nothing you can touch can we
make a comparison there yeah it's it's
like the tree having the trunk and then
the branches
and leaves also
we have
the shade tree of brahma yeah right yeah
okay so beautiful it's it's really
nicely uh thank you
all right how about some lunch game for
that right
and we can invoke gods for giving us
good luck
[Music]
i like the way believers here
find gods that best suit their own
beliefs
it's like a spiritual fingerprint
unique to each person
it's unlike the monotheism of the west
but maybe that's only on the surface
[Music]
on the surface hinduism looks like a
religion of many gods
but underneath the surface
there is a single divine energy
so why do some cultures see many gods
and some only one
where did the idea of worshiping a
single god first take root
perhaps it began here
stonehenge
britain's iconic 5 000 year old monument
the culture that built stonehenge had to
endure long cold winters
their survival depended on plentiful
crops
so it would make sense to focus on the
single source of energy that drove all
of that
the sun
an archaeological team is uncovering new
evidence that may reveal the beliefs of
the people who once lived here
we're going to look at the ditch
and the interior here
vince gaffney
and paul garwood have been studying a
giant c-shaped enclosure less than two
miles away from stonehenge
the enclosure called durrington walls
was built around 4500 years ago
and appears to be aligned so its opening
faces the rising sun on the mid-winter's
day
this is a ground pendulum radar vice
but what interests vince and paul is the
remains of an older monument they found
buried underneath it the radar located a
series of very large features there's a
long
arc of stones or large buried features
underneath the bank
so they've remained undetected
effectively for several thousand years
the hidden rocks are massive
each of them as tall as two men
they also form part of a c-shaped
monument
but the direction this sea faces is
different from the orientation of the
mound that buries it
there was an earlier monument
a very different form
on this site
it was looking towards beacon hill
this dramatic line of hills to the east
which is a dominant topographic feature
in this area and certainly must have had
significance at the time
vince and paul think the original
monument may be older than stonehenge
they don't know what its alignment to
their heels meant
perhaps the heels were revered as divine
or were associated with ancestors
but after the ancient britons built the
iconic stone circle at stonehenge
they demolished the old stones at
durrington walls
and made a new mound face the same
direction as stonehenge toward the
rising mid-winter sun
they've been pushed over and the bank of
the later henge monument has actually
been placed on top of them
it moved in its orientation its form
changed and presumably to some extent
its function
the creation of stonehenge itself
and the the building of the new
architecture down to wall suggested a
shift towards a greater emphasis on the
sun this is the main focus of worship
and religious interest
the builders were trying to establish a
very particular connection with someone
the people of stonehenge may have been
the first to worship the sun as a single
all-powerful god
but in focusing on the sun i wonder if
they lost something
when the gods were ancestors or rivers
or
mountains
they were much more accessible
easier to connect to to speak to
how do you speak to a god that's so
remote
i hope to find the answer
at my next destination
egypt
more than a thousand years after
stonehenge was built
an egyptian man also decided to worship
the sun
[Applause]
[Music]
his idea was considered so dangerous
that his memory was nearly wiped from
the face of the earth
thank you very much
today just a few mementos of his life
remain at the cairo museum
hey
oh there you are i know hello
amid the remains of dozens of pharaohs
egyptologist salima ikram
is going to help me find one whose name
is akhnatan
there he is
yep
he thought that there were too many gods
and not enough focus was on him there
needs to be a an important god
whom only i can channel so he changed
things radically he uh basically closed
down most of the temples said that there
is a
special god the sun god the arten
and that you can worship the atom
through me
and that didn't go over too well with a
few people no no that was not a very
popular move because of course all the
priests of the other important gods were
shut down
around the year 1350 bc hachnaten
declared the sun would be egypt's only
god
in doing so he would found the first
faith in recorded history with a single
deity
but it would not last
as soon as he died the old priesthood
struck back this piece has been hacked
away as you can tell you can see how the
name of the king is hacked out
the name of the artem is also attacked
everything there is tip tip tip tip tip
tip to chip and it's gone
away because destroyed it just destroyed
his memories yeah the best they could
akhenaten hoped his son would continue
this legacy but his son was only nine
years old when he took the throne
his name was putin common
here is the coffin of king tutankhamen
the most famous pharaoh
absolutely but he took the throne
at age nine
nine to nineteen only ten short years
ten short years i would imagine that a
nine-year-old taking the throne would be
under the
thumb
of the old guys who would say look we
can't keep this up we got to go back to
what works
absolutely he did what he was told
probably and effectively
his reign sort of knocked out
akhenaten's reign
and we have a return to the religion
i had to to the gods the old gods are
back in full force
truth and commons priests erased
akhenaten's monotheistic religion
and tried to erase him from history
here we go this
is
sarcophagus this is a sarcophagus or
what's left of it because it's all
smashed to pieces well
that's what you get
trying to change the world
well poor thing didn't
manage to change it for very long
do not fool around with gods
[Music]
well
octane's experiment and monotheism
failed
but i can't help wondering if what
happened
or around
1300 bc didn't influence the beginning
of another religion
because it was here on the banks of the
nile that jewish tradition says moses
was found among the bull rushes and from
that period
belief in the single god began to spread
around the world
how did the belief of a small band of
israelites spread so far and wide
today
almost 4 billion muslims
christians
and jews
worship the same single god
what was so special about this god
i'm traveling around the world to find
out how people of different faiths
connect to the divine
and uncovering how our ideas of who god
is have evolved over the millennia
my quest brings me to jerusalem because
half the people on the planet can trace
their god to this ancient city
it was here around 3 000 years ago that
belief in a single all-powerful deity
took root
i meet jewish philosopher joram hassani
to find out how one god won out over
many
this is the old city
the old city of jerusalem
and stores like this have been lining
these streets for thousands of years
except you know that thousands of years
ago they actually sold idols like
representations of gods like little
figurines in fact there's an
old rabbinic story go back time of the
talmud that abraham's father was a
idol shop owner
so
these idols what were these guards for
so the gods they represent in the old
pagan religions they represent anything
that a human being could want or need
there's a god that brings the reign
let's remain god you want victory on the
battlefield so there's a god of war
but you'd have to figure out how you're
going to please all the different gods
to get what you wanted right exactly so
some of those gods all they want is like
you know a party
they want wine and song and some good
food that's not such a bad thing
but some of those gods demanded
bloodshed
so you want something for me here's i
want something from you i want you to
sacrifice your son or something all
right how do i get now from the rain
guard i got a god of the fire to one i
can't see i can't touch i don't know for
sure is there oh that's what this story
about abraham is about abraham
looks around at all these different gods
there's got to be one set of rules
one set of laws of nature one set of
laws of morals that apply to all human
beings so what does he do where's he
gonna go all right let's take a walk and
i'll show you okay all right
[Music]
so right here we're looking at the
absolute
center of the religious world
this is it this is the place
we have over there the dome of the rock
[Music]
over there al-aqsa mosque
the mount of olives
and valley of gethsemane
and down below the western wall the the
holiest prayer shrine of judaism
why here for one reason exactly
when abraham almost sacrificed his son
isaac
it took place right up there on that
spot
now let's remember
abraham is surrounded by idolaters who
are sacrificing their children
murdering their own children abraham
thought that he was following god's
commandments by taking isaac up there
and and but god says to him
you're not going to touch your son not
this time
not for all time
there's one god
and he says you are not going to
sacrifice another child ever again
and commemorating that never again
is the reason that the jews build the
temple here and from their judaism and
christianity make this the holiest place
in the history of the world
that brings up a question though this is
an invisible guard there's no
no way that you can make an
approximation of it there's no idols
it's a single force that gives order the
physical order and the moral order to
all of mankind into our whole world
there's no representation because he's
not a local power
temples to the single jewish god stood
on this spot for almost a thousand years
until the romans destroyed the one that
was standing in 70 a.d
but that destruction did not end this
faith
one incredible thing about this is that
the one invisible god that's beyond all
things it turns out that you know when
you destroy the temple to that one god
you don't destroy the god you don't
destroy the god it turns out he's just
as much there as he was before that's
well put
it's understandable
the god of abraham was a god you could
commune with without any temples without
idols
for jews and also for christians and
muslims
this invisible god is always with them
no matter when or where they turn to him
it is truly amazing that three of the
world's great faiths
exist in such close proximity
all worshipping one god
the same god
a god who has survived calamities from
the destruction of the holy temple
to
religious violence
but how do you connect with a god who
has no physical
form how do you know
what's divine and what isn't
i've decided to return to cairo to try
and understand who god is to muslims
islam believes in the same god as jews
and christians
but i want to know if there are
differences in how they think about the
divine
historian of islam ahmed rahgab has
brought me to the al hussein mosque
and you can just come in here just like
the catholic church so it's always open
to prayer yeah if you want to come in
here and
you can hang out with uh
yourself and allah yeah absolutely
i'm just in time to hear what muslims
believe is one of the most beautiful
sounds in the world
the call to prayer
allah
[Music]
for the faithful
the song of the new zen is a
manifestation of god himself
so that's the end of the prayer is
by saying assalamu alaikum much like you
in you end an encounter with anybody and
it is because the prayer is essentially
a meeting with god
election like hey you know see you later
nice talk
see you the next time
prayer to allah seems like a
conversation with a person
[Music]
but how do you speak to a person who has
no human form
to help me understand
ahmed has arranged a meeting with the
mosque spiritual leader imam al-amir
mafuze
thank you so much for speaking with us
welcome
in the
christian religion god is so
manifested
but there is no such thing
in islam so who am i talking to do i
envision anything
you cannot imagine god
god is beyond imagination whatever you
would imagine with our human minds god
would be different from it
one of the
most
haunting
and
beautiful
sounds
in the world
is the muslim called the prayer
what was the
origin of that
uh it is said that one of muhammad's
companions had a vision
uh while he was asleep where he heard
this
call for prayer and then when he woke up
he went to muhammad and told him about
it and he's made it into this ritual of
using it to call for prayers every day
five times every day
how is he chosen do you hold all the
ships
there are auditions where they would
listen to people and the one who has the
best voice would be given the position
allah
[Laughter]
i get it
mosques are designed to be filled with
beautiful sounds
and images that delight the senses
from elaborate architecture to verses of
the quran written in the finest
calligraphy
many muslims see this beauty as a
manifestation of god himself
islam sees god in all things that are
beautiful
because god has no physical form
he can be experienced anywhere with any
of the senses
but these experiences are only ever
aspects of the divine
god is always more than we can imagine
across so many faiths around the world
and throughout time
people have emulated the divine
in the beauty of their temples
and glimpsed god and the splendor of
nature
but some faiths believe god can take a
physical form
[Music]
and that form
is a person
i'm in shiprock new mexico in the heart
of the navajo nation
i'm about to witness something that few
outsiders ever see
a sacred ceremony
where a god and a human
become one single being
welcome thank you thank you thank you
thank you
how are you we have something for you
too oh you do yes
look out
thank you you're welcome
where are we going now we're going
inside are we yeah all right i'll follow
inside the traditional navajo ritual hut
or hogan
the peterson family has agreed to share
with me the ceremony that allows their
youngest daughter mason to pass from
girlhood to womanhood
by the end of the four-day-long ritual
one of the navajo deities will be living
inside her yeah just like that and make
a cone oh yeah like a cone like this the
core of the ceremony
is the making of a giant corn cake in
honor of the sun how big is the cake
gonna be
it's gonna be huge
[Music]
are you the bartender yes
okay
mason's oldest sister kayla went through
this same ritual four years ago
and learned about her connection to the
navajo gods
or holy people
do me a favor
tell me about this ritual
so it's referred to as the kimasta
ceremony say that again
i had my ceremony when i was around 12.
and it's a puberty ceremony so it
actually originates from changing women
her we call her zed
i said not glenn
yes
pretty close
their story originated because they
wanted um changing women to bear
children so it all starts when first
woman and first man
see a dark cloud come over governor
dornot
and they hear a baby crying
[Music]
and him and first woman were instructed
to care for the baby by the holy people
so within 12 days she grew from an
infant to a 12 year old girl
in 12 days yes
she was ready to become a woman
to grow into a woman
mason must connect with the divine
spirit of changing woman which the
navajo believes still inhabits the
landscape
each day
she has to run toward the rising sun
do the young ladies
always run east in the morning
yes so it goes back on the story with
him changing woman as she becomes a
woman when she does bear children it is
with the sun
the holy people are around us right now
[Applause]
[Music]
this is an opportunity for the ceremony
where these prayers come apart
and push on her
and it's all about her
yes and yes
yes
so she gets all the the prayers
your hopes and your dreams that you want
for it just whatever positive you can
push into the cake and make sure that
her life is is strong and complete and
that she knows that she has
all these prayers that will
go with her
[Music]
as the corn cake begins its slow
overnight bake mason begins the final
night of her canal
tonight
she'll be joined with the spirit of the
navajo deity changing woman
she and her family will stay in the
hogan until dawn
while the navajo medicine man sings
sacred songs
all of these songs
prayers and blessings for
uh
the for the young girl yeah you can help
her along the way that she's desperately
changing to a young adult
that's why they sing for them as they
cannot okay to give them strength it's
what the run is about okay give them
endorsement
build them muscles and everything so
that way they change slowly into
womanhood
there are many more songs to be sung
tonight but hearing them all is
prohibited for outsiders like me
thank you you're welcome
see you we'll see you a bit okay
[Music]
at dawn
mason makes the final and longest run of
racconada
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
how are you feeling saying that i'm
gonna pass out you're gonna pass out yes
she's she's she's hot she's gonna pass
out yeah i'm glad it's cold out here
you're glad it's cold otherwise you
would pass out right
on this morning
the spirit of the navajo deity has moved
inside mason and made her a holy person
be proud your cake is good
that means that means
things are going to work out just fine
right
right
the cake can only be eaten once it's
been blessed by mason
i can take a bite of it yeah
don't burn your tongue
[Music]
now
that it's over
how do you feel
i feel like i say
i i say this i'm just like mom i
survived it felt like boot camp
great
in the canal
navajo girls have a personal experience
of the changing woman
one that can only be gained through rare
moments of insight
she is the spirit that infuses the
entire navajo landscape
if we believe that god not only
surrounds us
but also has the power to move inside us
[Music]
can we perhaps discover what god is
by looking inside our minds
for thousands of years to many people
god has been invisible intangible
a presence believers can sense but not
see or touch
but science may be about to change that
i took a train to philadelphia
to meet a neuroscientist who studies
what happens in our brains
when we have religious experiences
i'm about to see whether i can find the
presence of god
in my brain
[Music]
dr andy newberg
is pioneering a new field of study he
calls neuro theology
and i know that you are doing a lot of
research on the brain
how the brain reacts to
say spiritual meditation can you
elaborate on that for me
well certainly you know as we look at
the brain we can see very substantial
differences when people are religious or
spiritual
in their practices when they're trying
to pray meditate on god you know we can
see what's going on
in us as we think about god experience
god pray to god whatever the person is
doing so you're looking for
physical manifestations of god yes we're
looking for physical manifestations of
god
okay so
i'm interested in finding out if there
is any manifestation of god within
me in my brain right
uh we can take a look at that come on
see if we can find it
little pinch
ow i'm sorry i'm kidding
the process begins with an injection of
radioactive dye
what happens if you drop that
well if we spill on the floor we have to
close out the room and evacuate
everybody
so don't spill it okay don't store it
with your radioactive tracer in my
bloodstream and it can measure how much
blood flows to the various parts of my
brain
the more i'm using a part of my brain
the more radioactive diet will
accumulate
i already did a baseline scan while i
was just resting with my eyes closed
now i'm attempting to meditate on the
divine to see whether anything changes
it's time to start focusing on your
breath all right just try to get into as
good a state as you can focusing on the
breath just trying to really bring
really deep concentration to it i think
that'll be great so starting now you can
go ahead and start now okay
[Music]
okay
you can finish the meditation
how'd it go
fine how long was that uh it was about
11 or 12 minutes
before the radioactive tracer flushes
out of my system so you'll be on your
back i have to quickly climb into this
3d scanner
and see whether my brain has changed
because i meditated on god
all right well look at that two eyes the
nose and the mouth
but to me it looks like you're smiling a
little bit
what do you see or do you see
so these are your two scans side by side
here's your resting scan here's the
meditation scan
and you can see if you look at the
frontal lobes here
it's mostly yellow just a little bit of
red whereas if you look during your
meditation the whole front of the lobe
just kind of has blossomed so if you are
concentrating on something if you're
saying a prayer if you're focusing on
god if you're trying to connect with god
then you tend to increase the activity
in the frontal lobe how do i compare
with say
a nun prayer
or let's say a buddhist monk
who is meditating do i compare at all as
with the nuns who are concentrating on a
prayer the buddhists who were focusing
on an image they all activated their
frontal lobes and that's exactly what
you did too if i was contemplating the
image of god could you tell the
difference
we actually scanned an atheist who was a
very good meditator and we asked him to
concentrate on god to meditate on god
and he wasn't able to activate his
frontal lobes very much so in fact if
anything as you can see that sort of
decreased a little bit yeah so even
though they said yeah i'm concentrating
i'm trying to contemplate god they just
were not able to do a very good job of
doing it because they didn't really
believe it so i think part of what that
told me
is that regardless of
of what our practice is the key is is do
you believe it do you buy into it is it
important to you it's amazing that
somebody came up with the idea that you
could shoot somebody full of radioactive
drugs and look at their brain the brain
is just so unbelievably complex that
it's not that there's one god spot or
one god part of the brain but it seems
to be the whole brain that gets involved
and ultimately these change the way you
think and feel about the world
so apparently
it is possible to see physical
manifestations of god inside us
whether you're christian buddhist or any
kind of spiritual person
experiencing the divine actually changes
the brain changes the way we see the
world
that's really something
the evidence that experiencing god
changes us on the
inside will come as no surprise to
believers
including the people at lakewood church
in houston
i've come to see how ten thousand
christians can all have a meaningful
personal experience with their god
the pastors of this mega church joel and
victoria einstein
have agreed to meet with me before the
service begins
and let me in on their philosophy
i want to leave them something that they
can use this afternoon so i don't i
don't go a lot of doctrine and you know
i go practical today i'm talking about
you know using what god's given you and
so when you leave you'll say you know
what it was worth me going to church
today well let me ask you can we pray
we've got about one minute we're gonna
pop up there so i'm just gonna pray okay
yeah lord would you pray with us lord
thank you for this day yes and lord all
the people that have come out many are
gonna watch on television listen on the
radio and we just asked you that you'd
give us the words to speak that every
person would feel your presence your
power that they'd feel encouragement and
hope and inspiration that you'd know
that you have them in the palm of your
hand just ask your father for a great
service in jesus name amen amen
amen
thank you very honored to have you thank
you i'm very honored to be here we'll
catch you afterwards we got to watch it
stop coming you'll be dancing before you
know it
doesn't take much to get me started
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it is good to be in the house of the
lord and i am excited to be here today
with you
see we were designed
to function our best when we are
connected to god you've got power on the
inside you can rely on
don't live life in neutral not
passionate not intentional not focused
stir up what god's given you
dare to take those steps of faith
i'm asking a flat-out question who is
god i believe god is our father the
creator somebody that gives us purpose
and destiny you know sometimes it's hard
for people to say how can i believe in
something i can't see but it's what you
choose to believe through faith what you
choose to believe through favor
when jesus came he said look i want you
to come to me and so i tell people you
can talk to god all through the day like
you talk to your friend in your thoughts
you can say god you know thank you for
this day i think that god can be as
involved in your life as much as you
want him to be so that's what we try to
teach people to to get god out of your
sunday morning box
god has been a lot of things to a lot of
people
and now
here you're making god
personal yes
approachable yes
and
helpful that's right
the life of god
lives and dwells in us and it's a
spiritual life it's your spiritual
power on the inside of you
and that is what we need to tap into
[Music]
that was quite a show
maybe 10 000 people worshiping
celebrating
each of them having his own personal
experience with god
this is clearly
faith in the god in you
your inspiration
your power
god is so many things to so many people
the warm light of the sun
the sound of sweet music
[Music]
an inner voice that drives us forward
a friend
if you ask me who god is
i would say there's a bit of the divine
in all of us
this guarding you is god in me
the god in me
is
who i really am at my core
the god in me
is the best version of me
the god in me
is who i strive to be
who i was meant to be
[Music]
[Music]
you